before I let you go I have to uh there
are many things that I adore about you
but one is your guitar playing I think
it's such a hard instrument to
make yourself identifiable on because
some there's so many guitarists in the
world I always know it's you playing no
matter what effect you've done I always
know it's you and you've got that very
cool sort of staccato style that you
play that just always speaks to me like
oh I know exactly who this is
um that's so great to hear that it's
it's why because I grew up being a
drummer and and I didn't
I avoided the guitar because I thought
everybody plays guitar and just like you
said it's it'd be so hard to be unique
and I think that kind of turned me off
when I first sort of went to New York
and La when I was a teenager I thought
oh wow this is like ever it doesn't feel
special feels like everybody's doing
what you're doing right there's a 7 000
oh you're a drummer big deal there's
seven thousand drummers here you know or
whatever so I thought well I should
avoid that as much as possible but then
I realized it was
kind of the only way to really really
connect
um all the pieces together and present
it to other human beings in a way I mean
if you do poetry yeah you will find a a
certain amount of people who will listen
and pay attention and get something from
it but you'll find a lot more if you put
that to a Melody you know and if you're
a drummer you could connect to some
people but not really unless you sing
something along with it or play you know
say so really the way to to sort of
connect with others with art I mean and
music would is you have to sort of play
that instrument whether you're like a
not I think guitar or piano and
um so I sort of picked guitar from kind
of basically just teaching myself over
the years when I was a kid to
slightly how to play it you know I think
maybe that has something to do with it
if you're finding it unique
when you hear it it's probably because
of uh
my disbelief that I could be unique with
it right uh and sort of giving up on
that you know almost like oh whatever
you know I I maybe this will just get
tossed on the pile with all the other
guitar players so I might as well not
even try to be as good as them or try to
be as interesting as what they're doing
I'll just use it as my form of
expression and really I want to get to
the story and the the whole point of the
song is what I'm trying to get at this
is just kind of a McGuffin so maybe
that's has something to do with it being
I still don't know if I agree with you
that that it is that unique but if if
you're seeing that maybe maybe it has
something to do with those kind of ideas
well it is I do think it's your the way
you came at it is very different and I
don't not the only person that says this
but you're playing when you take a solo
and and eating your Rhythm Parts it's
very I just know it's you and I think so
many people uh when they approach guitar
what they really want to do is have a
Les Paul and be able to play very
smoothly and get this kind of they want
to sound like they're Heroes and I
always think it's our failure to be our
heroes I mean the people I grew up
idolizing no that's exactly what I was
just saying you you encompassed it that
way yeah we'll edit it so you said it um
when I hear you I don't hear a guy who
was working necessarily on I want to
sound just like Jimmy Page or I want to
sound just like this person or that
person and have this really smooth great
you you figured it out you said you're
miserably failing is what you're saying
to me yeah you're listening to the sound
of failure
you fail consistently and I just wanted
it but by the way why don't we get more
people coming into the interview this is
the last one we had left and so now
we're done yeah we've alienated everyone
now this is what I say to everyone here
it's your failure over and over again
Perpetual failure that's uh that's
brought you to me hey what is your
guitar why is it engraved Connie Stevens
because you know what it costs have your
own name put in there too many letters
yeah under the Connie opponents at the
Connie Stevens estate sale again
listen uh I want to let you go I want
you to have a great day rest up I'm
going to come see you uh tomorrow
um and uh I'm just it's it's a joy to
know you it's a joy to know you man
likewise it really is it really is it's
great I was thinking earlier when you
said that you know I think that you were
the first
uh well-known person or celebrity that I
ever saw in public and went up and said
hello to I don't know if you ever know
it was a bowling alley in Detroit and I
was there shooting a remote and
afterwards the time the writer Tommy
blotch and I went to this bowling alley
and I was bowling in Detroit bowling
alley that had like a bar next to it and
the next thing I know these like cool
young kids it was you yeah was Meg there
yeah Meg was in the Next Room with a
bunch of the garage rockers were there
yeah and for about a week I kind of kept
kicking myself like wow I don't know why
I did it why did I go up to him while I
was sitting at a dinner table and said
hi to him I mean that I shouldn't have
done that but it was so nice because we
we got along we hung out yeah we chatted
and then cut to like I want to say two
years later
um I see that you and mega playing SNL
and I go up and I don't remember you
from the bowling sure of course because
you were a kid yeah yeah and um
and I remember telling you it's your
failure oh God
that will be your success and that's
going to make you a success and you were
really bummed no but I came up to you at
SNL and I watched you guys rehearse yeah
yeah and um then you came over and you
went it's good to see you again and I
was like again I've not met Jack White
before anyone yeah we met in in Detroit
so you reminded me that we had met each
other and
um you were wearing a monocle I think
and
um very good this is all very good no
but it was one of the nice you just
didn't don't keep bringing it up Monaco
over you you were saying bring this up
as many times as you possibly can that
wasn't the challenge
it says monocle times seven
monocle
um I'm gonna have a corn cob monocle
made for you and I'll send it to your
wacky House of Horrors in Nashville
um Jack uh yeah that was a lovely
accident that we met each other all
those years ago and um and we've kept it
going and then you were kind enough
um when we came up with this podcast
there was one song I wanted we were
gonna be friends and you were like sure
you incredible price we had to pay every
time and place
um you're living solely off those
royalties now you haven't recorded
anything since
we haven't made a dime on this show yeah
we're in the hole we lose 600 000 a
month on this show but because but I
insisted on that song